-Here at "Late Night"
every night,
I deliver a monologue
comprised of jokes
written by a diverse team
of writers.
As a result, a lot of jokes
come across my desk that,
due to my being
a straight, white male,
would be difficult
for me to deliver.
But we don't think that
should stop you
from enjoying those jokes,
so we'd like to share them
with you now in a segment called
"Jokes Seth Can't Tell."
♪♪♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
These are two of our writers,
Amber and Jenny, everybody.
-I'm black.
-And I'm gay.
-And we're both women.
-And I'm not.
So, here's how this works.
I'll read the setups
for these jokes,
and Amber and Jenny will read
the punch lines, all right?
Here we go.
February is Black History Month.
-So find a black person
and leave them alone.
-At an aquarium in New Zealand,
a pair of lesbian penguins
recently welcomed a baby chick.
-You could tell
they were lesbians
because they were both
wearing tuxedos.
-A boy in Indiana called 911
to get help with
his math homework.
-That story again --
a white child went unsupervised.
-Singer Melissa Etheridge
is currently writing songs
for a Broadway musical.
-It's the first known case of
lesbians and gay men
being excited
about the same thing.
-Martin Luther King Day
was last month.
-And he saw his shadow, so
it's 200 more years of racism.
-A woman in China
has been diagnosed with
a rare type of hearing loss
that prevents her
from hearing male voices.
-Said women,
"Oh, please be contagious."
-Yeah, yeah, yeah. Very funny.
Very, very funny. Next joke.
-I'm sorry.
Amber, did you hear something?
-No, I did not hear anything.
-I know you can hear me.
-Of course we can hear you.
You have a lady voice.
-I do not!
"BlacKkKlansman" was nominated
for an Academy Award
for Best Picture.
-And white Klansman was
nominated for attorney general.
-According to a recent study,
the number of British people
identifying as lesbians has gone
up in the last five years.
-Lesbians or, as they call them
in Britain, crumpet munchers.
-A Texas sheriff has
placed cardboard cutouts
of officers holding radar guns
on the side of
several roads to deter speeding.
-And even one of those
managed to shoot a black guy.
-They said, "What?!"
-I don't know.
-Why don't you tell one?
-I don't think I want to.
-I think you should.
-I feel like if I tell one,
it won't end well.
-Oh, just one.
-All right, all right. Just one.
"Black Panther" recently won
the SAG Award for Best Ensemble.
"What's an ensemble?",
said lesbians getting dressed.
-How dare you?!
-You told me it would be okay.
-You should the be
ashamed of yourself!
-Black women and lesbians
are liars!
♪♪♪♪
We'll be right back.